opposers we are on the verge of a
constitutional crisis and not the kind
where I accidentally flushed my pocket
Constitution down the toilet and flood
the DMV No
one of our most courageous conservative
voices is under attack Laura Ingraham
Fox News host and woman who sent her
Cobb salad back to the kitchen three
times she is being persecuted by a
leftist firing squad for exercising her
First Amendment rights take a look
Ingram mocks high school senior David
hog who has been calling for tougher gun
laws following the mass shooting at his
school in parkland Florida tweeting
David hog rejected by four colleges to
which he applied and whines about it
hog wasted no time firing back tweeting
a list of Ingram's top advertisers and
asking his nearly 650,000 followers to
boycott all of them okay now 650,000
followers may seem like a lot but it's
anything like my Twitter most of those
are just BOTS and very real women in
bikinis literally begging to be my
girlfriend so since that tweet Ingram
has lost over 20 advertisers including
Expedia blue apron and slim-fast
slim-fast
have you no loyalty do you remember you
remember when Ingram said no one wants
to see fat people on the cover of
magazines in swimsuits yeah
you can't argue with that inspiring a
few hundred-thousand eating disorders
it's just the price of freedom
now nobody puts lower in the corner so
after taking a pre-planned vacation to
celebrate the miracle of Easter with her
family she returned to Fox's primetime
lineup Monday night to explain why her
losing Ruby Tuesday as a sponsor is a
threat to America we indeed are reaching
a crisis point where cultural walls are
now being erected to conscripted still
free speech in America their efforts are
Stalinist pure and simple pure and
simple Ingram is right this is Stalinist
pure and simple consumers in a
capitalist society using economic forces
to pressure corporations that is
textbook Stalinist communism
look it up and you'll learn how Joseph
Stalin famously starved millions of
Ukrainian farmers of ad revenue from a
prime-time Red Lobster commercial that's
history punks that's history right there
in a book if you trust it say a group
knows the First Amendment explicitly
says there shall be no law abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press or of
the right to be paid millions of dollars
to talk on the magic box that will be
invented in the future in fact it's
right here in my pocket Constitution mmm
smells like freedom and a bit like pre
drivers test panic urine so the point is
boycotts are on American case closed
but if you want to open it Laura
Ingraham made a great point on how they
can be effective against a deserving
target like Kathy Griffin until people
start standing up and say you know
something I don't tolerate what you're
doing I don't agree with it and I'm
actually not going to buy your products
I'm not going to support you know your
you know your economic partners or your
business partners I'm not going to do it
money does talk at some point yes
boycotts they're like sexual assault
allegations they should only have
consequences for liberals this attack on
our sweet lady Laura isn't just
advertisers distancing their brand from
one show it's part of a vast left-wing
plot to silence conservative voices the
targeting of conservative and
traditional voices in America the
censorship of conservative voices the
intolerant left bullies on the Left
aiming to silence conservatives yes I
know conservatives are being silenced
because I hear about it 24 hours a day
on Fox and 34 hours a day on Infowars
that's just how many secrets they're
exposing and what is this conservative
speech being targeted as it calls to end
abortion no is it sensible trickle-down
economics no is it pointing out the
simple fact that brown people commit a
hundred and ten percent of the crimes
never
fact Tucker covered that for 47 minutes
last night
they didn't lose a single sponsor just
keep on tuck in tuck no the censorship
hit Alex Jones when YouTube threatened
to ban his Infowars channel for
suggesting the parkland survivors were
crisis actors and Sinclair TV host Jamie
almond lost all his advertisers just for
tweeting I've been hanging out getting
ready to Ram a hot poker up David Hogg's
ass tomorrow yeah I'm being told I just
lost Quiznos for simply reading that
tweet guys this is out of control
they're censoring our conservative
bedrock principle which is mocking and
threatening traumatized children and
that's been a core republican value for
ages who can forget when Ronald Reagan
pushed a kid into a mud puddle and sold
tickets or Teddy Roosevelt's famous
slogan speak softly and carry a big
stick that you hit orphans with and of
course when Lincoln a Republican stood
on the bloody battlefield of Gettysburg
took out his phone and tweeted four
score and seven years ago none of you
cooks could get into Harvard so you stay
strong Laura the fight continues